It's just that the whole culture is so different to Europe.
That's what I think.
What about you? How do you...
It seems that, I mean, in a lot of our... where our travels take us...
...throughout Europe obviously and America, and Canada.
And there's not that much difference in American culture and Irish culture now...
...because we're so influenced by TV and by American culture.
And so, it's kind of getting closer and closer together.
So yeah, Japan is so different. It's great.
So, can I say that Japan is one of your favorite places?
Definitely. Yes, we really love coming here.
It's always... it's like being on holidays.
Okay!
So, what about the Japanese audience when you play live?
Oh, great!
Well, they get what we're about.
They understand what we're trying to put across.
Because I feel that the Japanese audience tend to be more passive about...
We were told that way back in 1997 before we came here the first time,...
...that we should be aware of that.
And that the reaction from the Japanese audience won't be what you're normally used to.
But that was totally wrong, they were great.
I think when people came out to see us, they knew it was going to be Irish traditional music.
And maybe it gives people a license to enjoy themselves.
I don't know.
You know, I have a feeling from talking to Japanese people...
...that they look at us as if we enjoy ourselves.
So, maybe people come... the audience feel, "Well, it's time to enjoy ourselves."
Okay.
Maybe. I don't know. That's only my theory, you know.